come on in okay
that'd be a cut why not [ __ ] really
okay
sorry
good shot
ever since i was a little boy
i would always beg my mother for a
little brother
but you know we were broke so awkward
before all could we all
it's live
everyone sitting at home just think that
tv just messed up
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh
[ __ ]
hello you know something like that yeah
hello
hello how do you feel mr david
how'd you feel mr harry
easy brandon you getting a little toothy
down there sorry
[Applause]
you smoke
who are you
just a i'm just a man who loves titties
woman
my job is done
peace
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i wish i could bring home more money hey
[Laughter]
[Applause]
douglas ephraim ben laser menachem
harrison
douglas ephraim ben laser menachem
harris
take gretchen palmer
to be a
douglas
i got it douglas ephraim been laser
managing harris
that was so good take it in your hand
and grip it lightly
oh that's good
now first take a deep breath and blow
don't suck
and then put your fingers
oh god
now wait a cotton pick a minute uncle
ben
i apologize i apologize uh why don't you
guys continue the meeting
i'm just gonna
grab a little car no but i'm actually
chocolate i'm not black at all
ridiculous
another likely story
look at those big chocolatey lips behind
them fangs
big old fat lips seriously
america
look at pete davidson's lips
[Applause]
i lived with the eskimos many years ago
and they used to plunge their faces into
the snow
mosquito
that's what you get
you laugh at me you die
[Music]
i'm sorry
you're really having a good time
mr t and and sting and and the rock you
think those guys are real that's a bunch
of dumbass nicknames by a bunch of
dumbass
it's [ __ ] up man
you understand what me say ballin i
understand what the [ __ ] is going on i'm
getting robbed [ __ ]
i'm getting robbed
[Laughter]
screw it
[Laughter]
when i rob you you'll just pay me what's
do [ __ ] i'mma call you 11 000
for a [ __ ] haircut this is a high
priced haircut tonight well shave my
balls then [ __ ]
here we go right what's the angle on
this one boys
[Laughter]
[Music]
right come on in what's your angle on
this what's it going to be
steve
i don't know what to do
[Music]
[Music]
me also said that at one point during
the altercation method man put a hanger
on the stove and left it for like 40
minutes and then
oh [ __ ]
the victim also said that at one point
during the altercation method man
allegedly put a hanger on the stove and
i may do it one time
the victim also said that at one point
during the altercation method man put a
hanger on the stove and left it for like
40 minutes and then
it's very hard it's very difficult lisa
bill cosby
mario party
tiny dick
and morgan mindy
no no no no sorry i'm gonna do
absolutely bursting down there
a couple of hairy coconuts all filled
with milk
pedophilia
and keith um
uh how would you say that oh queef keith
queef
and i should mention that we did not
know mr queef was inside so when he came
out it was a delightful surprise
um we will update you as we learn more
thank you stare into my soul
and i'll stare into yours command you
are not my wife okay oh that's it
i promise
[Music]
can i talk to you for a second showing
off what's up sugar
come on sam let's go
grace
grace
[Music]
thank you
is that the new copy of jugs it ain't
the new yorker
are guys really like that
no now oftentimes men masturbate to
women's personalities
my guy friends aren't like that
you know what shelly you're probably
right
they probably just push those big old
flapjacks aside and look straight into
your heart
that [ __ ] like me
put some syrup on them flapjacks and get
to eating
good girl
all right that's enough
right okay
okay yeah i'm gonna have a shower cheers
down
bad girl brandy bad girl
brad girl brandy